so do you think we live in a society now
that increasingly essentially thinks
that men are bad at some level
absolutely absolutely hello and welcome
to trigonometry I'm Frances Foster i'm
konstantine kissin and this is a show
for you if you're bored of watching
people having arguments on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
and trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts we ask the experts
absolutely fantastic expert guests this
week is an evolutionary psychologist and
author Jeffrey Miller welcome to
trigonometry great to be here it's great
to have you here the first question we
always ask is just tell our audience who
many of them will know who you are
a little bit about who you are how are
you where you are what's been your
journey through life so far well I'm
currently working as an evolutionary
psychology professor so I study human
nature and I work at a little place
called university of new mexico which is
actually in america in new mexico and i
spent nine years in britain so I'm
pretty familiar with British culture
throughout the 90s and I had um you know
pretty straightforward academic life
undergrad grad school postdocs yada yada
get tenure do research write books and I
guess over the last few years I've sort
of tried to cultivate more of a
public-facing persona on Twitter and
doing interviews like this because I
think there's a lot of stuff that
evolutionary psychologists in particular
know about that the public should also
know about and that's relevant to a lot
of current debates and so what is
evolutionary psychology because you know
there's so many different strengths of
it but how would you sum up it's a
science that really only started about
30 years ago it kind of started when I
was in grad school at Stanford and it
was sort of being invented under my nose
by some of the folks who are working
there like leda cosmides john tooby
david buss Steve Pinker
and some of those names you might know
it's basically the attempt to understand
human nature by pulling together a lot
of ideas and information from different
fields like evolutionary biology and
genetics and animal behavior and primate
research and hunter-gatherer
anthropology you kind of mix it all up
and you distill it down and you get
insights into what were our ancestors
doing and and what did they have to do
to survive and find mates and reproduce
and raise kids and live in groups so I
spend a lot of my time with my head sort
of back in prehistory right thinking
what was life like what were the
challenges like how did they court each
other how do they fall in love how did
they form relationships how did that all
work and you you know obviously it's a
little speculative but you do the best
you can trying to bring together these
different information sources you
develop hypotheses then you test them
and usually they fail you go back and
invent new and got more hypotheses and
test them and you know you try to get to
the truth and that's that's the game
that's evolutionary psychology and it's
a fairly established field now there was
a time when people kind of didn't take
it seriously but it is very established
and you talk about the fact that there
are certain things that you guys in your
field now know that the general public
maybe do not and in fact that maybe he's
being pushed back against by certain
elements so tell us a little bit about
some of those things what are the things
that you guys scientifically have
established about human beings that are
not known or controversial nowadays I
guess two big things I would talk about
is that there used to be a stereotype
kind of in moral psychology that if you
think about human morality and ethics
and how we treat each other there is a
view that in prehistory everybody was
kind of selfish and stupid and terrible
and then you invent civilization and
religion and kind of gradually make
people behave better
I think that's dead wrong I think our
capacity for kindness and altruism
and for signaling our moral virtues goes
way back really deeply like hundreds of
thousands of years and in modern society
we're also nice and virtuous and and we
try to be good to each other and signal
I think Virgin's turn the wings at least
a million years old directing someone
was doing that on the wolves I think so
like racism and racism is bad and behold
a mammoth that I killed the greater good
of the group and so I think that the
roots of human morality go back deep and
it's not just a matter of culture kind
of making us nicer hmm the second big
thing I would say is sex differences I
think evolutionary psychology has a
really good understanding of why men and
women tend to pursue different mating
strategies and courtship strategies and
have different priorities and
preferences when it comes to
relationships a lot of that is
caricatured and exaggerated in the
popular press a lot of it is sort of
taken up by like the manosphere and the
red pill guys and the men's rights
activists and sort of twisted and
distorted in various ways but I think
were a really useful counterbalance
against gender feminism let's dive in
right into that because you talked about
how some of those things are distorted
on both sides yeah so just for anyone
who doesn't know anything about men and
women who doesn't know anything about
evolutionary psychology can you just
break down what are the differences
between men and women physiologically
yeah and psychology and before we the
basic difference right that the
fundamental difference is females by
definition make a few larger gametes
called eggs males by definition make a
lot of smaller gametes called sperm and
a lot of else flows from that right if
you're the sex that makes only a few
gametes it matters a lot
who you choose as a mate right and
particularly if you get pregnant inside
your body instead of just laying eggs
right if you have internal pregnancy and
gestation and then breast feeding a
female human can only produce a kid
about every two or three years under
ancestral conditions where there's not
like a big food clot so her rate of
reproduction is very limited it's rate
limited and so for a female what really
matters is finding the best mate she can
get and then getting the most investment
from him that she can get from male it's
really different a male can potentially
produce as many kids as women he
copulates within a given year so you
have examples like a lot of European
males carry a y chromosome from one of
just three Bronze Age males who were
probably warlords or a local leader
Genghis Khan one right and then Genghis
Khan in Asia right right right
sired apparently a lot of kids who carry
his wife Buddhism and so that's a
massive difference in terms of the
upside of taking risks right if you're a
male and it's like I have a 50% chance
of becoming the local warlord and having
dozens of concubines but a 50% chance of
dying you roll those dice no doubt
that's a risk totally worth taking if
you're a woman and it's like I have a
50% chance of marginally improving my
social status and getting little more
resources for my kids or a 50% chance of
dying you take the opposite choice right
you're you're more risk averse so I
think that's a that's the kind of
fundamental difference is that males
chase status males are more risk
tolerant males are willing to go for
broke in terms of a lot of kinds of
competition from politics to sports to
academia to art to you know whatever
they're into and for women the returns
to doing those kinds of
have traditionally been in lower Jeffrey
and there's a question I want to toss
you saying Mauser more risk tolerant is
that the reason why we get more males in
prison than females statistically I
think it's one of the reasons I mean you
also have a basic sex difference in
aggression right what your male bodies
are literally designed to fight there
are dozens of aspects of the human face
and skull and muscles and and bodies and
and immune system that show we are
descended from guys who fought like a
lot and we're designed to do that can
you go into a bit more detail on some of
those aspects how we have designs from
that way well there's some recent
studies of even just the the bone
structure of the face showing men are
kind of built to take a punch more than
women the male brain is built to survive
rapid acceleration and deceleration of
the sort that you get if you're being
clubbed in the head more than the female
brain is and I think this is why like I
love mixed martial arts I love combat
sports it's great that women are getting
into it but I worry a little bit that
when women get into like striking and
grappling and you know jujitsu that they
might suffer different injury rates than
men do just because of these sex
differences and and the physicality and
and the sort of format ability that so
it's important to understand these
things just a kind of basic medical
level now I didn't expect the interview
to go in this way but there was a
there's been a debate especially in UFC
about there is a you know there's a
trans fighter who is fighting in the
women's category and by all accounts
absolutely annihilating do you think
that this person is at an unfair
advantage to women as an unfair
advantage over women absolutely of
course it's an unfair advantage if you
grow up with a male body and then decide
I'm going to transition that's totally
fine you can do that I'm a libertarian
do what you want with your body but then
if you enter into a domain where you're
fighting against women who've grown up
with women's bodies and have those
adaptations
physically and behaviorally like
nobody's really gonna care until the
first fatality but there will be
fatalities there will be fatalities when
trans women beat the living crap out of
women in these sports literally and then
we're gonna have to rethink is is this
really a good idea to sort of follow the
trans party-line about you know sports
inclusiveness and why is it do you think
that actually people are so reluctant to
address this if it's putting somebody in
physical danger well because they're
terrified of the reputational danger
that they they suffer from the trans
activists who are among the most vicious
and ornery and and and sort of dogpile
II people on the Internet
everyone's frightened of them everyone I
know who's involved in podcasting or
youtubes or public outreach or writing
for couette like those are the people
you have to be most cautious about and
so I'm even a little nervous sitting
here talking about them but they have
instilled the culture of terror it says
if you don't follow the way we want you
to talk about these issues we will
target you we will come after you and
will accuse you of everything bad we can
imagine as you talk about it I realized
that it must be true because the
conversations we have about this issue
are so dishonest now like I we had a
national debate about it like a week ago
where as a good morning Britain one of
the most popular shows they were
literally talking about is it an unfair
advantage or not and everyone knows yeah
you know there are physical differences
between men and women and you know you
talk about differences in aggression you
talk about how the body is designed but
there's you know there's bone density
there's lung capacity there's heart size
all of these things are different
between men and women
yeah and everyone knows it and yet we
talk about it as if it's it's a debate
what you know I guess a turning point
for me was in high school I was taking
Taekwondo which is a Korean combat sport
and I wasn't that good I was like a
green belt which is barely an advanced
beginner and then you do your your
sparring where you're supposed to sort
of show the ready to advance the brown
belt okay so I was I was pitted against
a college woman who was a black belt and
told spar go ahead and I was like sensei
I'm not sure this is safe because like
I'm five inches taller and I'm only 17
but I don't know if her skill can
overcome my just size and he's like
don't worry about it she's she's
well-trained and within a minute I'd
done like a round out roundhouse kick
and just knocked her flat out much to my
total chagrin she's a crush on her sorry
for knocking you out and at that point I
realized like society is fed a line of
[ __ ] about this and it is a danger
to women it was a danger to her and it's
also kind of an emotional danger to men
because we don't we literally don't
realize our own strength and if we're
being you know fed a lot of movie images
of like of course um you know this
female Marvel Avenger
you know female assassin could overcome
whatever the Hulk it's like no no she
couldn't it that like there's no
catching up once there's a certain size
difference so we got into politics very
quickly Francis and I had the idea that
we would stay away from it and talk
about it religious icons so let's keep
exploring so you talk about there's a
difference in aggression I assume that's
because again men evolved to fight well
what are some of the other differences
between men and women particularly when
it comes to things like preferences and
things that people are interested in and
pursued because that has quite a big
impact on our jobs careers you know
gender pay gap etc yeah I think so I
supported James to more the guy from
Google
who said there are important sex
differences and in personality traits
and there tend to be sex differences and
interests so one important thing to
realize is there is not an average sex
difference in IQ itself like overall
intelligence is pretty much dead even
between men and women and it's
disappointing to both sexes hope but
each sex desperately hopes the other sex
actually knows what they're doing
but there are there are differences in
preferences and interests like simon
baron-cohen
at Cambridge or Oxford wherever he is
now as shown you know men are more
interested in systematizing which means
kind of putting things in order
conceptually and that's why you get more
male train spotters really this is
exciting like the trains running on
schedule
I love stamp collecting and like
military history like oh no there's a
gap in my knowledge I must learn more
about the Ottoman Empire and women are
more on average into empathizing which
is kind of connecting with people
understanding their beliefs and desires
building social networks etc and I think
that's accurate and I think that
explains a lot of the occupational
differences right or men tend to go into
things that can kind of leverage either
their aggressive instincts like the
military or their tendencies to
systematize like coding computer
programming when women tend to go more
often into the caring professions
nursing Social Work etc and that's not
to say that any profession should be
only open to one sex I think yeah
there's plenty of high systematizing
females like my girlfriend who you
interviewed and there's plenty of highly
empathic men who might make great
psychotherapists so everybody should be
free to follow what they want but we
shouldn't necessarily expect any given
profession to be 50/50 so if I was a
gender feminist
I would be screaming at you right now
though all of the stuff may well be true
but it's the fault of the patriarchy
that men have been indoctrinated to be
aggressive it's toxic masculinity and
women have been indoctrinated to be
caring because those are the less paid
professions so that's where we shove all
the women you know evil patriarchy is
created this and we must smash it and
destroy it yeah well that's fine and
then I take a read some anthropology I
mean watch some BBC Natural History look
at the sex differences you see in other
animals the bizarre thing about the
gender feminist view right if you take a
broader cross species perspective is to
basically saying okay for the other
4,000 species of mammals you see certain
sex differences between males and
females to just happen to line up
perfectly with the gender differences
you see in modern humans and then
magically those mammal sex differences
got erased and we had a blank slate for
a few thousand years I guess yeah and
then there's this evil thing called
patriarchy that reinvents from the
ground up exactly the standard mammalian
sex differences and for reasons unknown
imposes them on modern humans like that
is the least parsimonious Theory you can
imagine right like why would you go to
all that trouble if it if it could just
be all we're mammals always have been
the other thing I think that's terrible
about the gender feminist view is it
basically invalidates all the
preferences of currently living men and
women right
it basically says to women you have a
false consciousness you think you want
this but that's been put into you by
patriarchy it's not a ballad view and it
says to men you think you want this it's
toxic masculinity you don't really want
it it's been indoctrinated your beliefs
are invalid so what are we gonna do have
one or two or three generations where
everybody's preferences about everything
are treated with contempt right that
seems to be the gender feminist view
that at some future point we will create
people whose preferences we can take
seriously but until that point we
basically have to engineer people to do
a whole bunch of [ __ ] that they don't
want to do know what you're saying with
the difference of sex difference yes you
made them feel
does it change a little bit with gay men
and women or is it very much the same
for them it changes a lot in some ways
and not much in other ways so for
example if you look at gay male mating
strategies like the preference for
novelty and variety and sexual partners
the gay men look a lot like street men
right
it's just gay men can act the way
straight men would want to act if
straight women were as open to casual
sex as other gay men are to other gay
men right yep yeah and so like I don't
know if I was in college and I could
have flipped a switch between being
straight and Gayle I might have flipped
the gay switch because it just seems
like so much more fun and so easy to be
able to find people who want as much
variety as you do
by contrast lesbian culture seems to be
much more oriented towards make the deep
connection with one woman and form a
long-term relationship and you know the
standard joke is like a third date for
lesbian is is you know move-in date it's
like get together and then live together
so in that way you kind of have the the
basic sex difference in what you want in
a relationship it just happens to be
directed towards a different sex than
usual because there's also talks you
know apparently with the gender pay gap
then the fact that lesbians there
doesn't seem to be that much of a gender
pay gap between gay women and men in
general yeah that's what I've seen and
you know to the extent that a lesbian
will have a slightly more
masculinize brain both kind of
genetically and hormonal and culturally
right a lesbians more used to kind of
playing the male role in certain ways
like they need to do that when recording
each other somebody's got to take the
initiative you might expect that they'd
be like more assertive when they are in
their job or asking for promotions and
raises then and straight women might be
and also I think gay and lesbian people
generally I don't know if this is still
true I suspect there's a little bit of
an IQ advantage in general where I think
on average for a little smarter they're
certainly more open in terms of this
personality trait of openness to
experience so I would expect that would
also play out professionally right where
you some of the advantage that you're
seeing that looks like a sexual
orientation advantage is actually just
kind of being smarter and more
open-minded and and more assertive and
also just having to deal with more flak
from society so getting a thicker skin
you know if if you're gay male it's hard
to grow up it's hard to go through high
school you have to be prepared to take a
lot of teasing from other guys and so
then if you get into the corporate world
and people are like making fun of your
PowerPoint like it's not that big a deal
compared to the teasing that you've
already suffered so so it's fascinating
so in a way you could gain men are
actually tougher a lot of the time than
straight now I think so I I think
emotionally and and in terms of having a
strong sense of their identity the irony
of course now is that I suspect most gay
men have a stronger sense of what it
means to be a gay man than most straight
men have of what it means to be a
straight man right there's a crisis of
masculinity most straight men are
terrified of being called you know
toxically masculine
and so a lot of guys don't know how to
behave unless the gay the gay guys know
how to be you think guys don't but you
said there's a crisis of masculinity
what does that mean because I hear this
a lot on Twitter and all the rest of it
why do you think there's a crisis of
masculinity I think partly it's an
engineered crisis I think partly it's an
intentionally designed crisis from
gender feminism which is to take away
all the traditional sources of masculine
virtue and meaning and to say those are
invalid right being a traditional hunter
archetype or warrior archetype is no
longer valid you're not allowed to do
that and then are like well what are we
allowed to do and the gender feminists
would not our problem we don't give a
[ __ ] that's for you and partly it's a
it's a crisis that's created by the sort
of legal atmosphere the me to movement
that the terror of being accused of
sexual harassment or stalking or
coercion partly it's the feminized
psychotherapy movement where you know if
men are having trouble in a relationship
and they go to a therapist which will
usually be a woman it'll be a [ __ ]
two on one you know women beating up a
guy emotionally saying everything you
want and believe in desire is
illegitimate and you have to change to
be more like us so I think part of the
part of the crisis is from my own field
psychology we were talking about this
before you got here with Francis and you
know I certainly feel like we're
starting to live in a society which
assumes that a lot of the basic male
desires wishes behaviors are in and of
themselves toxic and this is one we were
talking about just Jordan Peterson the
the number one question that I see him
being asked every single interview is
most of you following his mail and and
then they go into a question and it and
and the only way you would ask that
question I think is if you thought there
was something wrong
with being male because otherwise it
like Francis said you know if if it was
mostly women that were following someone
that would never even get brought up
because it wouldn't be considered
noteworthy yeah so do you think we live
in a society now that increasingly
essentially thinks that men are bad at
some level
absolutely absolutely yeah the whole
concept of patriarchy says a lot you
know the last few thousand years of
civilization where like all this amazing
stuff was invented and economic growth
like took off and were thousandfold
richer than our ancestors and life is a
hundred times better
that's all patriarchy and that's all due
to the oppression of women and
colonialism and men get no credit for
any of that even though it was mostly
men working on it at the sort of cutting
edge of invention and so basically the
last few thousand years of civilization
has been rejected right and everything
bad that happened is sort of put on men
and men are told yeah you're basically
the evil sex there's a possibility of
redemption which is offered by gender
feminism which says if you just become
more like women everything will be okay
the way you're saying it sounds so
soothing that's why I need to do I need
to become more like a woman see this is
where I was transitioning yeah but so
the thing is that I mean just to try and
explore the counter-argument what you
always try and do on the show a lot of
bad things has happened over the last
two or three thousand years there have
been a lot of you know colonialism was
there were elements of it which were
very bad right
I think it's indisputable that for a
long time we we did live in a very
unfair society that treated both
minorities and women badly I think no
one would dispute that I'm sure you
wouldn't yeah right so we're not an
argument to say well you know there's
excesses to this kind of extreme forms
of feminism but overall it's a good
movement we do need to move
woods you know as much equality of
opportunity as we possibly can and this
is part of that and yes there are
elements of masculinity that are toxic
therefore you know we need to keep going
otherwise men will be oppressing women
once again yeah so I'm I'm all for what
you call classical liberal feminism
right like my mom was a 70s and that she
did a lot of organizing with a group
called League of Women Voters which in
America helps get women out to vote and
promotes female candidates and organizes
political debates and so my mom was a
big deal in that local group but her
view was we just want equal rights we
want the right to participate in
political life and occupations and
careers and education and they were
fairly non theoretical like they didn't
have a strong gender feminist
explanation of society they just took a
practical approach that said if women
participate more in business and life
and politics then all of those places
will become friendlier to women and
represent women's interests better
mm-hmm and then I think feminism got
derailed in the 80s I think what
happened is you get the rise of academic
feminism and they're like oh the Equal
Rights Amendment didn't pass in the 70s
in America what do we do now let's
theorize about [ __ ] let's let's write
books about the patriarchy let's write
books about how terrible men are and
that's where I think it went wrong when
they kind of got into the business of
like this weird combination of ideology
and activism and scholarship and sort of
public outreach that said no matter how
much progress women make in equal rights
nothing will ever change as long as the
underlying systemic blah blah blah
patriarchy is intact so we have to
overthrow all of society all at once
good luck with that
and then everything will be
you know beautiful and equal and I think
that project has been a catastrophic
failure and is actually worse than sort
of the 1920s suffragettes or the 1970s
women rights movement and what effect
you think this movement has are men in
particular because I can see you know
sometimes men who being really not using
the word radicalize I think it's wrong
but I don't know another term to use
when they get confronted by this type of
thought yeah where people just say your
very existence is an affront to my life
almost I think there's two basic
responses if you ever are in a member of
a group where you're again and again and
again accused of being evil just because
you're in the group and this will be
true whether it's a sex or race or
religion or a political party or
football team supporter but whatever two
responses are you either like back off
and you sort of shut up about it
and you self-censor or in this case you
kind of self castrate right like you you
disavow the elements of masculinity that
they're critiquing or you lean forward
in like [ __ ] you I'm going to assert my
masculinity I'm gonna go for red pill
I'm gonna start reading you know first
Jordan Peterson and then the pickup
artists guys a Rollo Tomassi whatever
and I'm going to get radicalized in in
in the reddit communities and that's
both of those responses I think are sad
and counterproductive deeply unhealthy
as well yeah because the self castrating
guys were like I hate my masculinity I
hate it like that's sad like that's a
recipe for depression and alienation and
and and mating failure because women are
not attracted to that at all women are
not attracted to people who hate
themselves
and then the guys who go full red pill
but not in a smart way yeah right
can get so belligerent and spend so much
time fighting other red pill guys and
becoming such a [ __ ] and and turning
into trolls that hey that's not very
attractive either be it's kind of hard
to have a happy life if you sort of go
around in a way hating women and blaming
them for everything so what I hope is
that evolutionary psychology offers kind
of a reasonable middle ground where you
can assert your masculinity without
being a dick about it
mm-hmm I think that's so important and
that's why we were grateful that you've
come and talk to us because I think
these issues need to be talked about
because that polarization that we would
see in politics which I want to get on
to in a second it's happening in society
as well as happening between men and
women too and like you say people are
either chopping their balls off
essentially metaphorically or they're
becoming [ __ ] genuinely misogynistic
[ __ ] and you see it online all the
time and that helps no one because you
know I've always said this like the
historically the two groups of people
who've always needed to stick together
more than anyone is men and women yeah
that's the two groups of people that
have needed to cooperate throughout
history more than anyone right yeah and
if you take a step back from it and you
ask whose interests are really served
right by alienating men from women and
vice versa
and creating this like weird little
proxy war between the sexes I think the
answer is it's it's not really in the
interests of either sex I think it's in
the interests of kind of in a way the
corporate and political powers that be
in the elites and it's a kind of divide
and conquer mmm I think it's a lot
easier to control a population and in a
complex civilization like Britain or
America if you have quite a bit of
tension between the sexes I think also
at a marketing level it helps sell [ __ ]
because it creates profound insecurity
in both sexes
you know gods were like I don't know
what masculinity means anymore so I
better buy some more [ __ ] just in case
and the same thing happens with women so
I think if we could take a step back
from this battle of the sexes and ask
you know who's really profiting from it
obviously the political parties in
America or profiting from it I didn't
know to what extent that's also true
here but if you also have kind of
sexually polarized politics then then
people just take more interest in
politics hmm because everyone's
interested in their sacks and their
relationships and you know gender issues
and if you can politicize that man that
gets out the vote that gets people
passionate about a lot of political
issues and I think we're all being kind
of manipulated by by that what you just
said that was just incredibly worrying
really because the fact that we're being
manipulated manipulated do you think
it's avert what they're doing do you
think somebody is there making a
conscious choice or there's a group of
people making that choice I think
there's a group of kind of cynical
journalists who track you know what
pieces get reactions right and it's
mostly kind of the online journalism
world voxcom or whatever and I think
it's not that they intended to stir up a
battle of the sexes in order to create
you know more need and and insecurity
and polarization but I think they noted
that that is a direction you can go like
that gets clicks that gets a response
and so I think it's kind of marketing
driven I don't think there's a group of
people kind of meeting in a New York
hotel and secret kind of like how can we
make men and women
each other in that Newell society I
don't think it's that I think it's a
response to the kind of the combination
of men and women not really knowing what
their sexuality should look like in the
21st century and the social media and
social media journalism kind of
exploiting that insecurity and then the
political operators and pollsters and
campaign managers kind of noticing oh
this is an area where we can get
traction people are really interested in
this do you think do you see any do you
have any insight as to how we can move
on from this how we can start to move
back towards the right place of
connection between men and women and not
having that fracture in society in
general well I think you know the rise
of certain kinds of online culture and
journalism like you know these kinds of
interviews or the intellectual dark web
or Croat or places that are kind of not
quite academia but not quite mainstream
journalism that's great I think that can
help it really only reaches the minority
of people who care about kind of
articulating ideas and learning about
stuff I think the thing that would make
it go more mainstream would be sort of
public figures I mean Jordan Pederson is
kind of straddling this at the moment
right and he's got kind of one foot in
intellectual dark web but one foot in
the kind of Tony Robbins self-help mass
movement yes yeah and I'm all for that I
think that's awesome that's what I was
trying to do with my mate book a few
years ago frankly but I think what you
need more is maybe I don't know
celebrity couples going on camera
together and kind of explaining here's
how we manage this in our relationship
here's our power dynamics here's what we
do take it or leave it if it works for
you great imitated
or even better here's what we learned
from this other power couple I think you
have to personalize it and this is one
reason why my girlfriend Diana
Fleischman and I have been doing
interviews together is not that we
figured out everything but we think it's
important for articulate people to kind
of be more open about their own
relationships and I think that can be
quite healing that the kind of political
and ideological level I wish more people
did do that one of the things we found
in this country for example Teresa made
the Prime Minister well I think when she
first became Prime Minister do you
remember this Frances she came out and
said that in their relationship with her
husband
they have girl jobs and boy jobs there's
certain things that she does and he
takes out the rubbish for example right
yeah she got a ton of criticism for that
she probably got more criticism for that
than for the decisions that she made his
home secretary about immigration or
whatever you know what I mean so I think
it's gonna take a lot of people doing
what you were doing and other people
Francis when we become the celebrity
couple yeah we was one thing that I
wanted to talk to you about moving
slightly on and it's about marketing and
it's about how marketing companies use
every you know use our evolutionary
tendencies in order to manipulate us in
order to get us to consume would you
just be able to go into that a little
bit yeah so about ten years ago I wrote
a book called spent sex evolution and
consumer behavior and it was about why
do we buy goods and services really the
usual explanation from economics is oh
goods and services deliver utility and
pleasure and value and happiness to us
and that's why and like that's good that
makes sense for certain things like
whatever pizza but it doesn't make sense
of a lot of other aspects
consumption like why does anyone buy a
Bugatti Veyron 1,200 horsepower sports
car you know when you could buy a Honda
Civic and get around London just as
quickly actually or you know why do you
spend two hundred quid on a fine
restaurant dinner on a first date
instead of just going down to Nando's
chicken or whatever so I wanted to
understand kind of conspicuous
consumption but also I wanted to
understand things like educational
credential ISM college degrees why do we
want to get the Oxbridge degree so we
can brag about it or why do we prefer
taking dates to live comedy rather than
just sitting at home and watching
Netflix stand-up specials so my solution
of that was well we want to advertise
certain virtues and traits that we have
to others around us particularly mates
and friends and certain goods and
services are really good for ident for
kind of advertising certain traits that
we have like an educational credential
advertisers intelligence going to an
edgy live comedy performance advertises
openness right because you never know
what the comics going to talk about one
stage so you have to be the kind of
person who can kind of roll with it and
a highly traditionalist conservative
person is not gonna go see you know an
Anthony Jeselnik comedy show I mean they
might by accident second time anyway
yeah once there there was the date of
the Lucy path that oh so it was trying
to understand what I think a lot of
marketers already know but don't say
which is that they're not really selling
the thing they think they're selling
they're selling an ability for this
person to advertise this trait to these
other people through the product Wow
so in a sense
what we're really doing when we're just
buying anything is we're displaying
signals yeah it's all signals so I mean
there's been a sort of gold rush to use
signaling theory to explain a lot of
aspects of human behavior the last few
years I've been doing it Robin Hanson
with the elfin and the brain has been
doing it a lot of people suddenly are
talking not just about virtue signaling
and in politics or Twitter but just
signaling in general and it's great
because I think signaling really
explains a lot and I think even Darwin
in the 1870s understood signaling
explains a lot
so what about tattoos because I've
always s was something I really wanted
to ask because before tattoos were seen
as something you did if you were a
social pariah or a convict but now I
mean I've got one but why is why do we
tattoo now I still see it though I mean
yeah that's a good question and I didn't
get tattoos at all until the girlfriend
made me watch on some reality TV tattoo
things like ink master yeah which is the
big American competition between tattoo
artists so I've watched way more hours I
think master than I would want to admit
yeah and I do I don't have any tattoos
but I do at least appreciate the
artistry and the culture and the
different styles and how much it means
to someone to kind of make a permanent
commitment to like this is part of my
identity this is a significant event in
my life this is an important person in
my life and I'm gonna just seize it as
part of my my persona and display it so
everyone can see it I think there's a
kind of admirable courage in that I
think it's also a highly risky strategy
because people can like change their
minds about who they're in love with or
what their identity is is or what their
political allegiance is or
you know what their aesthetic taste is
so you can end up with the sort of oh
god this I don't want anyone to see this
because that was you know ten years ago
and I'm a different person now it's like
a tweet you can't delete yeah yeah
that's a tattoo is the undeletable tweet
yeah yeah and I don't know if you have
any thoughts on this Bob just since
we've gone down this this track of the
conversation do you have any kind of
interesting thoughts about of the
changes in how people look and dress and
like hipster beers puzzle me you've got
this like 20 year old with a beard like
down to his knees like what's that all
about I think for a lot of men it's it's
a search for authentic masculinity and I
lived in New York in 2013 when I was
teaching in the business school there
and I dated a woman who lived in the
sort of epicenter of Brooklyn hipster
culture so I got very very familiar with
hipster culture and I kind of loved it I
loved the respect for the past
and the sort of sense of connection to
like dads and granddad's and doing the
same kind of [ __ ] that they did and
going the same kind of barbers and like
and buying things that were intended to
last not just til next fashion season
but for like four decades so I really
appreciated that sort of sense of of
temporal continuity mmm the attention to
quality and craftsmanship and this sort
of artisanal dis and artisanal that like
I actually thought this is better than
the throwaway hyper consumerist culture
that you saw before like in 80s at the
time I kind of appreciated the overlap
between the hipster culture the CrossFit
culture of the paleo movement which I
was involved in and but I thought
fundamentally at least for the men it
really was about a sort of pushing back
against the gender feminization
of men and it was sort of saying I'm
gonna grow a beard goddamn it and wear
boots and be strong and be decisive
about what kind of art is an old bacon i
order for lunch and whatever and i had a
lot of respect for that and i guess in a
way it informed writing the mate book
which was sort of dating advice for
young guys not an explicitly hipster
book but it kind of took lessons from
that that movement it faces the one
place you know I'm just gonna watch a
quick question because you know we're
not was in my 20s I really struggled
with identity and finding someone and
you know and dating but it's just awful
it's just if you've got some tips from
four men who are looking you know and
they want to meet someone they want to
display value and they want to you know
attract a mate what's it five easy ways
for instance of displaying value for
instance buying read my mate book we
cover a lot of this also in the mating
grounds podcast yeah which is online and
free in whatever but I would say them
the main things are number one get
physically strong like do things that
will make you physically strong lift
heavy things
number two wear clothes that fit and get
advice from women and other men about
like how to do that you wouldn't believe
like if I get on any given you know
London Overground
train and look at what the guys are
wearing my eyes are bleeding how is
anyone with two x-chromosomes supposed
to look at that and go yeah
and Jeffrey Miller destroys British man
yeah that'll be the clip Jeffrey British
male taste is substantially better than
Albuquerque male and I think what else
read more nonfiction and watch less TV
probably or listen to more podcasts with
interesting smart people and and watch
less TV or do anything and play fewer
video games like I don't have I think a
lot of the Matis fears in this panic
about you should never watch porn and
never masturbate and never watch video
games and that's just dumb but I think
like pay attention to how you're
allocating your leisure time and if
you're allocating your leisure time in a
way that builds you up into a more
interesting person women will notice
mm-hmm ventually and you'll feel better
about yourself and more confident about
approaching women and then finally
online dating is awesome and just find
an online dating app that actually lets
you showcase what is good about yourself
if you look awesome
then tinder is great but if you don't
look awesome find some other dating out
other than tinder that lets you share
more of your intelligence and creativity
and verbal skills and humor and whatever
so yeah that's my team the train your
body train your brain listen to
trigonometry
[Music]
well listen before we've got about ten
minutes
let's talk politics a little bit I'm
curious because I think as an evolution
psychologist you might have quite some
insight into the place that we are at
now in terms of how divided we are how
polarized we are how tribal we've become
bigger and and that strikes me like I
see that instinct within myself to go to
find the tribe and to go oh this is what
I am everyone else is evil
fight fight fight and I have to resist
that urge within myself but I think a
lot of us we don't we don't do that we
just dive in and we start attacking
other people so where where are we how
are we there what what is it about us as
human beings that makes us that way and
how can we depolarize ourselves I think
one important thing to remember is that
when humans were evolving for the last
couple million years we were very often
in contact with other hominids other
bipedal hominids running around on two
legs with pretty big brains who were
different species or different
subspecies who weren't who were
literally not us like they weren't us
they were competing with us and we get
kind of confused because were the last
hominid standing like we out competed
all of them and they went extinct some
of them we we poached some of their
genes like the Neanderthals or
Denisovans or you know whatever but we
didn't evolve in a kind of multicultural
kumbaya kind of setting where everyone
right we evolved to compete against
other beings that kind of looked like us
and kind of didn't and where we weren't
probably not very nice to them and not
very welcoming that's not the same so we
probably killed them brutally let's be
probably we call them really but we've
probably also just kind of out competed
them and like we got this cave and they
didn't get the cave and there they are
freezing to death and we don't give a
[ __ ] hmm so one level it's absolutely
astonishing that you can have a
multicultural city like modern London
with millions of people from hundreds of
countries and not have massive like
ethnic riots all the time it's amazing
we can achieve that that's not something
that could have been predicted maybe 500
years ago so I think when people go oh
no were so partisan and racist and
xenophobic it's like compared to what
compared to what standard compared to
angels maybe compared to what you would
have expected given our evolutionary
history it's astonishing that
multicultural societies work as well as
they do and they don't work perfectly
and maybe they're not optimal but you
know the evolutionary perspective lets
you just give people a little bit of
credit for things being as peaceful as
they are it's not just the evolutionary
perspective for me some when it comes
from Russia as an immigrant to this
country first generation the perspective
of having lived in places outside on
Western Europe and North America it it
teaches you very quickly about how
tolerant and welcoming and accepting and
not homophobic and all the rest of it
this country is or this part of the
world is yeah and I think we've
definitely lost a sense of just like
what are we comparing to absolutely but
I think there is no there's no question
that our societies are now more divided
and it has been for a while not ever
of course that's ridiculous but then
they have been for a while in America
the political side of it as we talked
about you know the race and genders
become I mean I don't think anyone sees
the next Democratic nominee for
president as a straight white man I was
just not going to happen is it yeah and
and that's how that's how predictable
has become right so what are some of the
ways that we can start to take to take
that edge of politics and start to come
back just to a genuine conversation
about issues and
it's really tough I mean there's there's
basically two paths that you can choose
to go one is kind of double down on
multiculturalism and say this is the
path forward and let's figure out how to
make it work as well as possible and the
other path is the kind of freedom of
association that says you know what if a
certain group wants to like sort of take
over a certain neighborhood or gated
community or city and just have it for
them then they should be able to do that
and just like nothing wrong with that
that's the historical norm is it's quite
is that sorry is that the position
you're advocating I think it's a thing
that's worth experimenting with a lot of
people would be troubled by that I know
suddenly yeah well they could be
troubled by it and then can they they
can form their own community where they
can get together and be troubled by but
is there not an argument for a nation
Jeffrey the idea that we are all let's
say British right we all come to this
country we will integrate we all talk to
one another we all understand we all
have a common set of values we maybe
have a national service where we all go
and meet people from different ethnic
groups and whatever I know a lot of
people you know one of our recent guest
Peter Hitchens talked about the fact
that one of the problems with mass
immigration is the people don't
integrate and then everyone lives in
their own ghetto and I certainly would
someone who's an immigrant I would be
troubled if there was a Russian ghetto
of a hundred thousand Russians in the
center of London yeah I would be
troubled by that oh it's otherwise
called my fur but that's a very
particular thing right so I I would be
very worried about living in a society
where essentially we all became our own
little tribe that lived in its own
little place and we're not you I don't
see that as still being a nation really
right so what you need is if you're
gonna have a nation at all right it's
either got to be an ethnos state where
it's sort of defined by ethnicity or
it's got to be civic nationalism yeah
where it's defined by shared language
values education mass media
everybody buying into like the same
criminal justice system and the same
norms for how the sexes relate and how
the mating market operates and all that
and you can totally have civic
nationalism that can succeed it
succeeded okay in America and in Britain
what you can't have is a nation where
it's fake civic nationalism where you
give lip service to civic nationalism
but you don't actually have integration
mmm right if it's like welcome to
Britain you don't have to learn English
welcome to Britain you don't have to
respect our criminal justice system
welcome to Britain you don't actually
have to join our educational system I
think that's a recipe for for
catastrophe yeah I think that's why a
lot of people that's why I wanted to
clarify what I said because a lot of
people would have heard you saying that
and I think a lot of people would be
troubled by as I am I'm troubled by that
you know I'm troubled by that I think we
do need a genuine civic nationalism
where we all have it we there are some
values that everybody understands as
being British values we all buy into
that and unfortunately that's not the
direction that we seem to be going in
you know even saying that seems to be
all you're racist it's somehow you know
the idea that we should all have a
common set of values or a common
language or ya know whatever but I think
well the other thing is I'm not
necessarily advocating civic nationalism
because I think it's important to
realize it is an experiment it has not
withstood the test of time for centuries
it's not typical of most nation states
throughout history it's also not typical
of most nation states currently around
the world yeah right China is a Han
Chinese ethno state right it's more than
95% Han Chinese they have no interest in
making it into a civic national that's
not their goal they're not they're not
going to be like we love Russians come
live with us Russians that's not going
to happen so it remains to be seen in
the coming decades how does their model
of a kind of technocratic long-term
thinking slightly despotic like ethno
state and how well does that play out
compared to let's say multicultural
British setting actualism do I hear you
suggesting that they're probably more
competitive yes as a system well who's
gonna colonize Mars first China
obviously yeah who's going to nominate
the world in terms of soft power China
I think obviously hmm so I think it's
important to you know while Europe and
America are sort of squabbling about our
partisanship and toxic masculinity and
whatever we're worried about to keep our
eye on the fact that we've already kind
of become a sideshow to the main current
of civilization which is Han China and
and I'm in a way I'm sort of more
interested in what they do long term
then what happens in Britain or America
well just to stick for a second with
what's happening in Britain America
before we go to our final question I
wanted to talk to you about free speech
because it's something that you're
passionate about it's something you've
spoken about I think you kind of really
started speaking out when the James the
more thing happened yeah and you know
we've had some experience with this in
the UK but talking about free speech on
campus in America tell us what's
happening there because we watch it from
from here we hear about people being no
platformed violence on campuses all of
this stuff where is that because you
have that enshrined in your constitution
there's a very kind of important
principle of your civilization almost
right what is happening with free speech
in the United States particularly on
campuses situations getting a little
better but very very slowly I think five
years ago is probably peak censorship in
terms of almost nobody respecting free
speech rights I've been involved in my
university and faculty
Senate I kept trying to pass resolution
saying we are a public university
technically we are an arm of the state
we are a part of the federal government
we are not obeying the Constitution we
are we here's a dozen policies to
violate the First Amendment than the
other senators would be like so what we
don't give a [ __ ]
free speech is an outdated medieval
concept of the free speech in medieval
times and so when when Trump came out a
couple weeks ago and said I'd like to do
an executive order that says it man if
you're in a public university and you do
not follow First Amendment free speech
principles I will cut off federal
funding I was like yay this is what we
need I've been advocating that for two
years that is the only thing that will
get administrators to take free speech
seriously nothing else will I know
because I've tried it and then sadly
some of my free speech colleagues were
like this is terrible this is top-down
we can't have this associated with Trump
and are you guys kidding if Obama had
done this if Obama had said respect free
speech or I cut funding everybody would
be going yay at least the pro free
speech left hmm
so I think I'm guardedly optimistic that
Trump might follow through on this I
hope if he does an executive order that
it's well written and that it fits
constitutional law I hope that
universities will react to it by saying
like you're right we were bad we were
bad and we're gonna try to you know play
nice according to the Constitution my
worry is it'll just create more
polarization and people be like [ __ ] you
drama weren't free speeches just to
cover for hate speech and and we're not
gonna do any of this and because there's
a lot of people who believe that you
know free speech like you said is a
cover for hate speech can you just hold
take her or not and somebody whose
mother comes from Venezuela company if
I'm asking this question but why is free
speech on campus
outside so important I'm sorry for the
question but I have to ask now free free
speech is important generally because we
should all be humble about what we know
and what we believe and open to changing
our minds and you can't have an open
public debate that shares information
freely if you have certain groups of
people saying that's forbidden that's
forbidden that viewpoint is invalid
you need to actually have a
rough-and-tumble like radically honest
conversation in society now the trouble
is that actually depends on the
infrastructure of civic nationalism it
actually depends on people knowing a
common language having some common
values having some common historical
education and some common sense some
common sense and we don't have that and
then the second part is why is free
speech so important on campuses is
campuses are the point of ideological
indoctrination in America that's where
you learn the proper views that you're
supposed to have and the left has
understood this since the late 60s right
they realized we're in a culture war we
win the culture war by taking over K
through 12 education and higher
education and indoctrinating people to
have certain values and telling them
certain other values or be on a pill and
they succeeded they they won that
culture war and the only way to win it
back is a advocate free speech and be
make better arguments well speaking of
free speech and making better arguments
it's been a great interview Jeffrey and
our last question always is what's the
one thing that no one's talking about
that we ought to be talking about I well
I've got an in I got in this effective
altruism movement about five years ago I
teach a course on it and I think the
thing that used to frighten the crap out
of me was artificial intelligence but
the last year or so the thing that more
frightens the crap out of me is what
always
frighten the crap out of me in college
nuclear war nuclear war is still the
biggest existential risk that humanity
faces nuclear winter is a much stronger
risk than climate change right what is
climate change
oh no the climate might get two or three
degrees hotter nuclear winter is like oh
no the climate might be 20 or 30 degrees
cooler that's a bigger risk and so what
I don't see politicians and citizens
doing is talking seriously about there
is still a lot of nukes they're still
out there
we just had India and Pakistan almost
escalate into that China has nukes
Russia's Knicks this is still a live
issue but it's almost like we're bored
we're bored with nuclear war man we've
like we've all seen the Terminator
movies and and that's so 20th century to
worry about that I think we could be
blindsided by it all right we don't want
to be in a situation where we go oh [ __ ]
we lost our species on our civilization
because we got bored with the biggest
existential risk and we kind of moved on
to this relatively minor ex risk like
climate change bioterrorism or AI so
that's the thing people aren't talking
about and I highly recommend the book
the doomsday machine by Daniel Ellsberg
the talks about just the nearly
continually catastrophic bad nuclear
strategy that the US had throughout the
Cold War that almost blew us up over and
over and over and over again so that
deserves more more attention I think
fantastic Jeffrey well thank you for
coming on yeah if you enjoyed this
interview follow Jeffrey on Twitter at
primal Polly by his book the mating mind
you've got other books as well haven't
you spent and mate spent and May and the
podcast reminds the podcast oh the
meeting groans the mating grounds follow
us as always at trigger pod on all the
social media subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the bell button next to a
subscribe button
what iTunes as well yeah leave a review
on iTunes and sometimes guys we've
noticed a little trend that people on
YouTube say they have been unsubscribed
could you please just check it for us
and if it's subscribe unsubscribe
subscribe again and let us know because
we're going to start kicking up a bit of
a fuss about it
alright guys thanks very much we'll see
you in a week's time see you later bye
bye
[Music]